the global economic outlook for this
year might be less gloomy than
previously predicted although that's not
the case for the UK
Britain is the only member of the group
of Seven Nations whose economy is likely
to shrink in 2023. according to the
international monetary funds January
forecasts the country has been grappling
with a cost of living crisis with
discontent spilling out onto the streets
with months of strikes we have told the
government that is an increasing problem
while the U.S and other nations have
begun to rebound from the pandemic the
UK has been struggling to turn the tide
the UK's flagging economy now looks set
to shrink by 0.6 this year
even being outperformed by sanctions hit
Russia here's why
Energy prices worldwide soared following
Russia's invasion of Ukraine in the UK
inflation is close to its highest in 40
years largely driven by those high
energy costs
Britain was hit particularly hard as it
relies on natural gas for much of its
power generation and as limited storage
capacity
meanwhile the U.S was able to knock down
prices domestically after the government
released record amounts of oil from its
strategic petroleum reserves in many
countries for example the U.S inflation
is beginning to ease thanks partly to
policy tightening by central banks the
Federal Reserve hiked interest rates
multiple times last year in a bid to
curb inflation it now appears to be
paying off
consumer spending is starting to falter
and price increases are easing
suggesting that the U.S economy is
slowing down the UK Central Bank the
bank of England also raised interest
rates to try to slow inflation yet UK
prices have continued to rise rapidly
grocery prices surged nearly 17 percent
and the trade Association the British
retail Consortium says prices have yet
to Peak
workers across sectors have suffered a
decline in inflation-adjusted wages
especially those whose salaries are paid
for by the state
strikes from workers such as train
drivers postal workers nurses and
teachers have become a familiar site
across the UK
[Applause]
so we increase except for our pay our
work
another problem for growth is that the
country's employment rate has yet to
recover to pre-pandemic levels unlike
most other G7 Nations the UK is
suffering from a decline in the
workforce with a number of vacancies
close to record levels many have taken
early retirement and Britain's exit from
the EU has put more barriers in place
for workers from the Block meaning gaps
aren't able to be filled as easily
to compare in the U.S where the
unemployment rate is at a multi-decade
low the total Workforce Rose to a new
record in January however there are
signs that the tide could also be
turning the bank of England has
moderated its economic growth forecasts
for the UK which are previously very
negative it thinks that while Britain is
still expected to enter a recession that
it's likely to be shallower and shorter
than previously feared and it says that
inflation is likely to drop sharply this
year the bank of England raised its key
interest rate on February 2nd but it
signaled that it may pause soon meaning
the economy won't have to endure further
sizable increases in borrowing costs
we have seen a turning of the corner but
it's very early days and the risks are
very large
and it's really that that I think shapes
where we you know where we go from here
[Music]